Come on!
Cholee!
Yippeee!
Mmmrh
Yeeeaaah!
Ooooh
Combination A7?
Yea
Let’s go!
Bunny hop!
Spin move!
Wohoo!
I've got it!
What are you doing?
Good receive!
Aaaah...
I had it!
Come on Miikka
Mine, mine!
Your turn!
I’ve got it!
Ha ha!
We're so good at doubles!
Introducing
the legendary
defence player
Emil
Paddlehands!
Let’s go!!!
Faster!
Come on!
Well done!
Good!
We got this!
Gets some water
Some energy!
Yes
Fix the hair
Next set
More long serves!
Let’s do it!
Come on!
Good job!
We got this!
Woah?
Thank you!
See you tomorrow
See you!
Forgot my keys!
Good session Otto!
Watch out!
You saved my life
No worries
Otto!
See you tomorrow
See you!
Where’s my keys?
Good training Otto
WAIT!
He's a chopper
This will be easy!
Good match!
Ah good
He's a chopper
This will be...
easy?
Okay that's mine!
No!
And drop shot
Alright
Thanks for the match!
Yeah... thank you
Show your racket
Okay
Pongfinity Sensei
Oh, that means it's official
Love all
Time!
I wonder where the umpire is?
Oh yea!
She’s coming
Hello?
Yeah!
Yes
Come on!
Still leading!
Yeah
Good call
I also think that should be a red!
Emil, what’s wrong?
Nothing!
100% of your socks
subscribe to our channel.
It's a very good day!
Yes!
Emil, what's wrong?
Only 18% of our viewers
are subscribed to our channel.
We could have 10 million subscribers
if everybody would subscribe.
Well, let's hope
our viewers
who aren't subscribed
will do it now
Click subscribe right now.
Hard
and then slow...
Why?